is solid as a rock a strong silent type
who doesn't show much emotion he spent
his entire career playing for and then
coaching veda bremen
after four decades there he decided to
take a break from the beautiful game
but he couldn't stay away for long and a
year later was back as coach of
frankfurt
so what attracts a rational man like
chef to the highly emotional world of
football
would you describe yourself as an
emotional person
yeah yes of course everyone is emotional
we might express it in different ways
but we are all emotional
what does being emotional mean to you
it's important
it permits you to express things
while others are a bit more reserved but
that doesn't mean they aren't emotional
some have to scream and shout while
others stay calm
but the feelings are still there
and what kind of a person are you
a bit of both
a bit of both
if i compare you and say jurgen klopp on
the sidelines at a match there's a
difference in the way you express
yourselves
from emotional australia
jumps two and a half meters for joy
because his team has played a great game
in the champions league
well i can't jump that high anymore
if we score a goal i'm more concerned
about how my team reacts thereafter
rather than about celebrating
and i won't have much time to react if i
spend five minutes celebrating
and you'll see that many clubs concede
goals right after scoring ones
themselves
because they're distracted
and if you know that you can try to keep
the celebrations to a minimum and help
your team
so you suppress your emotions
i don't have to suppress anything the
emotions are still there the joy is
still there it's just the reaction
that's different
how do the players handle your
analytical approach
well i think i don't just take an
analytical approach emotions play a part
too it's not just one or the other order
give us an example of how your emotions
come into play when working with players
yeah if you can when a player does
something right i can provide him with
additional motivation to keep on doing
that
through clear commands or in action
i can reach out to him
and encourage him to do the same thing
again
to keep at it to give him support
that can be very emotional
so it depends on the squad's mental
state
yes it doesn't make much sense to kick
someone when he's down you have to try
something else
you need to have a feel for it and a
sense of what's required at the moment
how did taking a year off affect you
personally
i might not have been so considerate
for instance if i took a trip
it wasn't so important if i came back as
planned or stayed two days longer
don't you miss that freedom
there's the danger you could get used to
it yes
but on the other hand
i'm very very happy to be working
you